um please be upstanding for the chairman
of the council thank you
thank you members I'm going to ask you
to remain standing for a moment please
um you may have heard there was a tragic
car accident
this weekend
um three students from chipping Camden
School were killed in an accident but
they're all residents in South
Warrington
I'm going to ask for a minute silence
please
or remember them because it's a tragic
loss of life and it's certainly that
younger age
well man thank you
thank you members
I now like to introduce Reverend Katie
cross
to do an introduction to this evening's
this afternoon's meeting thank you thank
you we've got a prayer as we begin
together
heavenly father as we head towards the
end of this Council cycle and look
forward to the local elections we give
thanks for all the good work that's been
accomplished by this Council
we bring to mind the highlights
we also bring to mind the hardships
we give thanks for those who've
contributed to the life of this district
and especially to those who may be
stepping down
we pray for integrity for our counselors
and for wisdom for our communities as
they seek to elect the councilors for
the coming season
and so we lift the members of this
Council to you for the business of this
meeting
we pray for a productive time that
discussions will be effective and
decisions will be clear
we pray that important things will be
tackled with sensitivity and wisdom
give this Council solutions that best
meet the needs and benefits Those whom
they serve in the name of Jesus Christ
thank you
foreign
thanks everybody for coming today
um we'll go straight into the meeting if
I may uh apologies for absence please
chairman apologies have been received
from councilors Bromwich Kendall and
Wally hoggins thank you thank you
members dischargers disclosures of uh
interest if you have any uh disclosures
you would wish to mention now and
Council walks straight in there if not
if you pick them up at the appropriate
time if not now Castle Rock well thank
you chairman I see we have a motion on
defibrillators on the agenda although
it's going to go to Cabinet but I want
to declare an interest as
a former ambulance first responder and
chairman of the napton defibrillator
group also as a personal receiving end
of a defibrillator shock
the cabinet can judge the value of the
equipment based on this experience
so they do work okay that's fine
well it's good to see you here anyway
there you are thank you for that
uh minutes
um as you'll notice on there that again
Council Rock uh thank you for spotting
the uh the error in the minutes that is
just for noting
right we're going to move into
announcements
I'll say we don't need to do that
apparently
okay so I'm told that we do need to
agree the amendment are we all in
agreement
thank you very much
now we can move on to the announcements
uh first announcement
um I'm not sure we all want to sing it
but happy birthday to Pena
happy birthday Sonia
um I'd also it's a real privilege
to give our staff a long service award
and today we've got Neil Neil shado
would you like to come forward Neil
all I all I'll say is well done for
sticking that out so long here it can't
be too bad a place to work can it
thank you very much indeed I'd just like
to say now the probation period's over
I'm looking forward to a long long
government career thank you very much
thank you very much
[Applause]
okay Howard should we we're going to the
right I'd like to just run through a
number of the things that have been
happening this last period which has
been quite
an intense time but anyway
uh over to you yes
right this oh
try it again
all right this is the Wags gang show
with the uh the scouts and guides
let's meet you in the middle you know it
was a really really impressive
performance and I decided I'd say this I
was actually really impressed with the
choreography there as well and the
enthusiasm of these young young people
amazing time really thoroughly enjoyed
that one next please
this was hosted in this chamber I
invited a number of students from some
of the schools in Ulster as a sixth form
and uh students to come along and do a
debate this was all part and parcel of
what I've been doing with the schools
over the last year and the University of
Warwick which is an introduction into
local government
uh I like to think they got an awful lot
out of it I did we had a thoroughly
enjoyable time and we have also uh
hosted two primary schools in here as
well now and Manuela of course was uh
instrumental in that particular thing on
the first school from me on Vale it's
been really interesting to see the kids
enthusiasm for this and they've all come
away saying what a great time they had
this was a full-on debate as well so it
was no unlocking about they had to
actually do the debate and the results
you never know you never know what the
result's going to be so it was a really
interesting time and and thanks for
hosting it okay
right you are now the proud owners of a
tree
this is the Stratford District council's
tree it's a Sycamore and it's on ragley
estate and it's the fourth one down on
the right hand side when you're ever
over there so if you look for the new
Avenue there
they actually have planted I think 70
trees one for each year of the Queen's
uh rain
and they've they've all of them are
different but I think they're all
supposedly anyway all British Woodland
trees
so you now have your own tree now as you
can see the weather was beautiful
we uh I think the the mayor and I were
quite glad when it was over yeah you're
on the next one please
and Lord Hartford was certainly there
telling us what to do so there we go
and as the mayor also got one as well so
that's quite impressive next one please
we've now been to a number of the
performances at the RSC and I have to
say that
their mixed reviews I think is the
expression isn't it Julius Caesar was
quite an interesting one
um black blood never got that quite got
the hang of that particular part of it
but it was a very powerful performance
but I think that it was one of those
that you say you love it or you hate it
it's one of those Marmite moments the
next one though
I found that absolutely fascinating
hamnet which was effectively the the
well Hamlet was written by Shakespeare I
think or we believe based on his son's
death
ham net uh and it was a very very moving
very powerful performance
we have had the Civic dinner so
saving money
changing the planet we had a joint
dinner with my uh my wife who's mayor of
Ulster so we did a joint dinner this
time
which was very enjoyable we thoroughly
enjoyed ourselves
um oh at least no I did anyway and I
think yes the smallest one in the back
there as well next one please
uh and there's there with our uh mayor
of Warwick uh yeah everyone seemed to
have a nice time next one please
including the leader
and I'm sure Willie was enjoying himself
but you never know do you next one
please
the other thing that's been an amazing
part of this year has been going to all
the core societies and especially quite
often in Holy Trinity and the Gloria was
very very powerful a massive Choir in
there uh it's quite sunny and moving as
well very very good next one please
oh ass Elton John so I didn't get
invited to out in John but I'm going to
show off because I went to see him and I
thought it was a really good good time
there next one please
and this was the uh the service my my
service my Civic service based on
volunteering so the theme is
volunteering and the two young ladies in
the middle there what I call serial
volunteers
they are quite amazing they've done so
much uh for the community bonding all
over the place they are really an
example so yeah well done for them and
they did and they did feature in the
service next one please
and then of course it was a
Shakespeare's birthday celebrations
and I now have my own Outfitter and
Jason's now going to be looking after my
my dress sense for the into the future
is that correct sir Jason
whatever
next one please
and there's the quilt of course that was
on the Sunday we had the the uh the
ceremony in the in the church in the
Holy Trinity there so it's been quite a
packed time and that's not all of them
obviously but uh that's a sort of a
recap of what we've been doing it's been
quite an intense period hasn't it John
right thank you
okay now then
I'm just going to
have a little is he got a note in front
of you
which is on the announcements or the
first announcement sorry uh do you want
to do it though no it's okay thank you
the first announcement is the um
those counselors
who are are not standing in the
forthcoming elections or perhaps may not
be re-elected
so I thought I'd say a few words if I
may
first I'd like to say a big thank you
for all your help and support over the
year making my term of office such an
enjoyable one in other words by not
giving me too much of our time
I do intend thanking all the staff who
supported me properly at the 24th
meeting but I will say a few words now
as well
to those who will not return next term I
wish to offer both mine and the
council's thanks it's not easy being a
cancer
and it does have an impact on your home
lives however you can be confident that
we leave the council in a better
position than we all joined
covert was a challenging time for us all
the council immediately Rose to the
challenge and we swiftly put in
procedures that allowed us to operate
efficiently during that time despite
being the fourth hardest financially hit
District in the country due to covert we
continued supporting our residents and
businesses throughout the time that was
real teamwork
things in local government do not always
happen as quickly as perhaps you would
like them to for example a number of the
major projects we started years ago and
only now started to come to fruition
these projects will benefit the entire
district and I'm sure that you will
continue supporting them into the future
not everything of course has worked out
to plan the political merger with
Warwick did not happen however the
collaboration between the two
organizations continues to save money
and thus protect important services
all of what I've said is down to you our
councilors with the excellent support of
our officers
so whatever happens on the 4th of May I
think you can be duly proud of our
Council and thank you
so it's in the words of The Bard I quote
from Julius Caesar I've never done this
before
and whether we shall meet again I know
not therefore our Everlast lasting
farewell take forever and forever
farewell
if we do meet again why we shall smile
if not why then this parting was well
made
thank you
a leader announcement
thank you chair I will be brief and I
have no photographs so I apologize for
that uh
since the last meeting of council I've
attended a meeting of the Growth Company
board and I've been to a number of
meetings concerned with the formal
winding up of Coventry and Warwickshire
local Enterprise partnership which I
have to say I think is very sad because
I think it was an extremely effective
organization that actually delivered
benefits for this District thank you
chief executive thank you chairman no
announcements for me thank you
short and sweet
there is no public participation today
so I will now move on to item six
independent remuneration panel and I
asked councilor Jefferson to introduce
this report
thank you chair
this report seeks to extend the current
appointments to the council's
independent remuneration period for a
period of 12 months with the intention
of advertising for a refreshed panel
membership as from the 1st of May 2024.
you can read the current panel members
at paragraph 1.4
I would draw your attention to paragraph
one four three
and that the IRP will be conducting the
major four-year review this autumn in
view of this it's considered vital that
it retains all the valuable experience
built up by the existing members in
recent years
145 the individual members of the panel
have been consulted they're all willing
and able to continue in the role if
council is also agreeable and 146
it's important that members of the IRP
are both independent and seen to be
independent so the intention is that a
recruitment process will be carried out
in February 24 to refresh membership
so without further Ado can I propose the
recommendation on page 27 that the
extension of current deployments to the
independent remuneration panel for a
period of 12 months from the 1st of May
2023 to the 30th of April 2024 be
approved and I called for a second
please
yes Council Pemberton are all members
agreed
thank you
item seven is the Constitution
uh for ratification of the various items
that are on the appendixes uh I'm now
invite Council Jefferson again to
introduce this report
thank you chair
uh this report asks members to ratify
various amendments to the Constitution
previously agreed by Council or made by
the monitoring officer under delegated
powers I should say there are 57 of them
so I hope everyone has paid close
attention to them
uh
paragraph one four changes to the
Constitution reserved to the council say
that the Monitor and officer is
authorized by Council to make amendments
where that Administration administrative
changes are required
and all those are detailed in appendix
one
so I think this is in and paragraph one
five in view of imminent all our council
elections and the potential for our
relatively large number of newly elected
councilors Community to office members
are requested to ratify the amendment's
independence one I think this is fairly
straightforward and the law doesn't
require the Constitution be kept to date
so without further Ado the
recommendation on page 31 that the
various amendments made to the
Constitution are set out in appendix one
be ratified I propose the recommendation
chair can I have a second to please
Council Fielding thank you
are all members in agreement
thank you
moving on to item 8 fenney Compton
neighborhood development plan I invite
councilor Pemberton
Deputy leader to introduce this report
thank you very much chairman um
Philly Compton uh
I'm sorry
if any Compton
neighborhood development plan went to
its referendum that sounds like it could
have started nursery rhyme and went to
its referendum on the 2nd of March where
there was a huge endorsement of the
neighborhood development plan with a
turnout of just under 21 and 134 votes
in favor and no and nine votes uh voting
against
um first of all I'd like to place on
record my thanks to the members of the
Fendi Compton neighborhood development
plan group for all of their hard work in
bringing this
very comprehensive document to fruition
and I'd also like to place on record my
thanks to the members of the planning
policy team that have supported the
Fendi Compton neighborhood development
plan group in working through the
process of bringing the plan together so
the recommendation before you members is
that the fenny Compton neighborhood
development plan be adopted with
immediate effect which has the
consequence that it becomes part of the
development plan for stratford-upon-avon
district thank you can I have a second
up in that please
Council Rock
how did you just speak Council
and then
um that's loud isn't it I'm suffering
from your disease Council of Pemberton
you're speaking I have to speak quietly
I just want to Echo um uh councilor
pemberton's bird uh they've been working
on this plan all the time that I've been
representing for any Compton for the
last four years tremendous amount of
work all sorts of holes to be overcome
I'm sure this applies to other
neighborhood development plans but uh I
just want to agree with everything
that's been said Thank You chairman
thank you
uh are we all in agreement
moving on to Long etchington's neighbor
development plan Council Pemberton
thank you chairman the longitude
neighborhood development plan has also
been to its referendum on the 2nd of
March the ballot generated just under a
19 turnout with 360 votes in favor of
the plan and 31 votes against
um therefore the the community has
endorsed the longitude neighborhood
development plan as with the previous
plan I would like to place on record my
thanks to members of the longitude
neighborhood development plan group for
all of their hard work and diligence in
bringing another really robust and clear
local plan into being at the same time
they have been ably supported by members
of the planning policy team and I would
like to place on record my thanks for
their work also some members the
recommendation as with the previous item
before you is that the longitchington
neighborhood development plan be adopted
with immediate effect with the
consequence that it becomes part of the
development plan for stratford-upon-avon
district thank you
thank you can I have a second for that
please
answer Adam would you like to see see
thank you very much
our last members to cast their mind back
to seven years and think where they were
well in Long itching turn a small group
of people were getting together to um to
start the work which is uh culminated in
today
um I'd absolutely like to Echo councilor
pemberton's thanks to officers as well
and very glad to see this come through
thank you very much
thank you and I think we all appreciate
just how hard these neighbor development
plans are to produce so well done to
everybody there thank you
oh we agreed
thank you
right uh moving on to item 10 a minute
732 series violence Duty there's a
separate cheat out for this
um I invite Council Jefferson to
introduce the report so
thank you chair
um just to be clear that on 31st of
January 2023 a new statutory Duty the
council came into effect namely the
series violence Duty
uh it's worth saying that whilst a duty
did not specify a lead authority to be
responsible for coordinating the
activity there was a general consensus
among partner of agencies at
Warwickshire County Council were best
placed to fulfill that role and it is
actually worth mentioning that councilor
Crump is the responsible portfolio
holder at Warwickshire County Council
um
I think in regard to questions raised
regarding the new burden and available
funding uh fondly would be provided for
dedicated county-wide lead officer plus
funding will be made available to the
southworks community safety partnership
so cabinet recommends to council to
adopt the serious violence strategy
which is appendix 2 to the agenda report
and to include it in the council's
constitution in the list of council
plans and strategies and to amend the
terms of reference for the overview and
scrutiny committee to include a specific
reference to scrutiny of crime and
disorder and serious violence duties
this is a complex issue it's not going
to be easy to tackle but I think this
provides a sound foundation for doing so
so without further Ado can I recommend
uh
one and two two Council please
thank you can I have a secondary for
that please
so counter Kettle thank you very much
Council unit
um first of all I have to declare an
interest in the time the chair of Ulster
youth project and has been for the last
10 years and I just wanted to be able to
say that I welcome a a partnership
approach for early intervention and
prevention and want to be able to
support the work that so many
communities do to try to do that into
early intervention role whatever they do
in whichever way they do it
one of the things that I would like to
be able to suggest going forward if you
don't mind is that many of the
organizations that work with young
people are now increasingly bit pursuing
the same funding from Charities and
trusts and it is the funding that I I
have questions about going forward one
of the suggestions that I might make is
that councils have an opportunity to
assist by either investing small amounts
in core funding to help those groups
access further funding and to coordinate
and write funding bids or give them
advice that might be something that
might be helpful
there is also a way in which councils
can work by sharing uh assets and
finding innovative ways in which they
can work with Communities going forward
to bring Partnerships together so I act
put those in place as suggestions
because the early intervention
Foundation estimates that if earlier
intervention isn't taken it costs nearly
17 billion pounds in late interventions
with much of these costs falling on
councils so it's a matter of making sure
that we prevent rather than have to pick
up the pieces later on so thank you very
much
thank you Council kettle
as portfolio holder for Community safety
this is a
and I point out two who cancel this is a
further task
on this Council to work with communities
to improve their lives and the safety of
those within the community
firstly I'd like to congratulate the
community safety team
who
work quite often outside everybody's
site
working those with those people who need
this Council support
and it is uh they do that incredibly
effectively those of you who had the
benefit of working with our antisocial
Behavior team
which I have with individuals who have
antisocial problems or where there is a
a more public antisocial problem where
it needs not necessarily a police
approach but an approach which is able
to mediate between two different parties
one way or the other
um the CCTV team
incredibly successful in supporting the
police we have a as my written answer
later identifies
we have a very successful team
that is able to work hand in glove with
the police
the rural crime team or the rural crime
advisors again incredibly important
to those communities outside the the
bigger built up areas
so
this is yet another task
and I think as counselors we need to be
very aware
of the very significant commitment the
community safety team keeping this
council's residence safe
this task is is a further role a further
burden for them to take up
and the fact that we may very easily be
picking up
um serious case reviews where people
have died on top of the existing
responsibility of a domestic homicide
reviews which for those of you who've
held this office before and I know two
of them uh are in this Council
are pretty traumatic roles to have to go
through the line by line where things
went wrong
and the fact that we're now picking we
may variously have to pick up the same
sort of work for serious homicide
um again is a significant task so I do
commend this paper I do recommend I do
recommend the recommendations that's
made but most importantly I would like
to recommend and thank the team behind
this paper and for the work they do in
keeping and trying to keep our
communities as safe as possible
thank you we have a proposal secondary
uh are we all sorry oh cancer Crump I
did I did
okay Mr yeah um officer I'm slightly
mentioned in the report and I do share
the safer Workshop partnership board at
the County Council and partnership is
the emphasis you know we can't do this
on our own workshe is a net importer of
serious crime and violence and and
organized crime gangs as well
so it is about working together
um there are great relationships now
being adapted and evolved between
ourselves the county the police and
other partners and it was good to see
that uh the police and the police and
crime commissioner came to osc the other
week and was certainly held to account
and challenged by the members of the osc
committee I can see some here nodding
that they were able to change them so I
think this is about working together
um but we as members have got a role
it's not about just about Community
safety it's about Community intelligence
and where are the eyes and ears were
about in the community and we need to
pass any concerns on because sometimes
members of the public our residents have
concerns about personal and and worries
about them so make yourself available to
your residents get the information and
pass it on because if the police haven't
got the intelligence they can't act on
it so thank you very much
thank you councilor any other
comments
if not I have a proposal a second are we
all in agreement
thank you
right moving on to item 11. uh councilor
questions
uh right let's start councilor Council
field Inc uh do you have a supplementary
question
um not at this time although the current
portfolio holder knows my feelings on
certain matters I won't take it any
further thank you thank you very much
cancer and on question two again Council
Fielding do you have a supplementary
question
yes it's um I had a very interesting
discussion with the chief executive on
this problem following a meeting of the
comma which committee it was about the
fact that Atomic units are very safe and
they are used in atomic submarines his
question was do you think that we could
get an atomic submarine up this far my
answer to that was
um it wouldn't fit up the even I'm just
wondering if he's got any further
comments to make on the matter
well it's an interesting comment you
know my particular views I think that
that is a a future technology but it's
not one for the uh the chief executive
to comment on but thank you councilor
off do you have any uh supplementary
question
uh I do thank you chair
um yeah it's kind of a bit
unsatisfactory that the numbers are so
low
um but can I be assured that there will
be appropriate security at the polling
stations in case of any issues of ID
um and I do hope that the staff at
polling stations will be a little
lenient
when it comes to issues of ID thank you
Council council do you want to comment
on that
well I'm could you repeat the question I
do apologize I apologize
okay um so it's uh uh it's a little
unsatisfactory that the numbers are so
low
for request for ID can I be assured that
there will be appropriate security at
the polling stations in case of any
issues of ID
and I do hope that the staff at polling
stations
will be a little lenient when it comes
to ID as well thank you
things
thank you cancer Rolf I apologize for
having to repeat the question but the
second time it was much clearer
um the
um clearly it is not our choice to
implement this the the idea of having ID
voter ID was implemented by central
government
um it is not I suspect a problem that
was that needed to be resolved in this
District but the law is the law uh I'm
sure officers will be as lenient as they
can within the law they cannot be seen
to be breaking the law the the um
officers do have a responsibility to
uphold the law
and electrical registration officer is
personally responsible
for the management of an election
process in this District
I cannot would not be at all happy for
him to be to be proposed to him to be a
lenient if that is not within the
legislation
I'm sure they will be as helpful as they
can in terms of the loan number of
applicants
that has been significant amount of
advertising all the emails have gone out
there's been advertising in the Press
about the need to have voter ID and it
will continue
um if voters do not choose to take up
the offer
because they haven't seen those
advertisements
um then and they're not aware of them
then that would be incredibly
disappointing it may be
that the vast majority of District
Council residents already have their own
ID I don't think we have any statistics
to say whether we are better or worse
IDs in this District than we may be
another in other areas
I'm sure they'll as always the officers
of this Council will do their very best
to help those residents who have
problems on the day and it may be in a
matter of saying
had you brought your driving license
you'll be able to vote uh and clearly if
you go home we will make sure that your
ballot paper is still available for you
but at the end of the day they do have
to uphold the law as enacted in
Parliament and the electrical
registration officer cannot be part of
any
softening of those legislative
legislative terms
um because people haven't people haven't
read about it
thank you Council
council pettigella do you have a
supplementary question
uh no thank you thank you Council
franchally
do you have a supplementary question
uh thank you chair
um I when I read this I didn't think I
would want to say very much but um
I've no doubt you've all noticed that on
my way here today I have been to have my
hair cut
thank you
um yes
the young lady cutting my hair lives in
Windsor Street
and she is she was telling me she's so
frightened to go out in the evening
because of the ASB along Windsor Street
she has reported this several times via
101 and nothing ever happens it just
Carries On
so I'd like to put that for you to
consider thank you thank you very much
uh thank you councilor probably
um
the 101 is service not run by the
district council who's won by the
community run by the community safety
team it is an alternative telephone
number to contact the police
um and that is therefore matter for the
police to resolve uh and I think a lot
of people have had concerns about these
people with 101 uh calls are answered
um I do know that the police and crime
commission as part of this year's budget
has put in additional resources into the
101 team to try and improve the response
rate from that team certainly
conversations I have had with him along
with other members of The Plea the South
Orange Community safety partnership the
police and crime panel
um have have pushed him
on on the importance of people getting a
satisfactory response to 101 I have to
say one of the most effective ways of
reporting 101 given that this is not
relating to an existing crime that is
taking place at the time
this is an after the incident
reporting mechanism that the use of
emails which are available on the
website are a farmer a far quicker way
of getting information in the system
um and therefore does not result does
not require people to sit on the end of
the telephone waiting for somebody to
answer so I would recommend to anybody
that actually
if you do have an instant report on 101
very seriously consider using the email
way of reporting rather than the
telephone because the information still
goes back on the same database but
clearly a well drafted concise email
covering the Salient points about
whatever that individual wishes to
report
is just as effective as having a
telephone conversation with somebody
else who's thinking how to type exact
same items into the same database and
I'm reassured those databases are
collated they are available to SNT teams
so
um what I would also recommend is that
people do not give up on the 101 service
until repeatedly that where there is a
burgeoning what you might call mailbag
email bag
of
concerns about a particular area a
particular group a particular type of
crime cancer
brief please that that does trigger a
response with the SNT teams
cancer Junior do you have a
supplementary question
let me know what work is happening
currently with housing associations to
find a pro appropriate alternative
accommodation
the only thing I can say really is well
yes we will Carry On from doing that
um
and that that's because that's an
ongoing issue as these numbers increase
I was also quite amused to receive this
question beforehand from Preston Whits
at the herald as well so I've given
another answer that you'll hear in the
herald about my views on Building
Council housing in the future
thank you councilor
council patiala do you have a
supplementary question uh yes please
chair thank you
okay
um first when will small businesses be
able to register for free on the new
Shakespeare's England website I thought
it was going to be from the 12th of
April but we haven't had any
announcement so will Ward members be
contacted so that we can let our local
businesses know of this opportunity and
second I understand the Shakespeare's
England does not directly Lobby
government could the portfolio order
find out and clarify this for me please
thank you councilor Percy Geller
um I'm actually attending a full board
meeting of Shakespeare's England
tomorrow an all-day session when I hope
to get an update but certainly
um the
um David platts's team have already
provided information so that all
business rate payers will be informed of
the opportunity to register their
business
for the free listing on the
Shakespeare's England website you will
note in the response to the question
that SDC is supporting Shakespeare's
England extensively which which
initiate was initiated September 2022 to
September 2024 a total of 200 000
predominantly because Stratford was the
fourth worst hit
District in the whole of England and we
recognize the need not just to support
the tourism businesses but also other
businesses as well
could you possibly repeat the second
part of your question councilor
pertigella yes
um I understand the Shakespeare's
England does not directly Lobby
government
um I don't know whether they do it as
individuals or they sit on other boards
so just to clarify that for me thank you
Shakespeare's England works very closely
with visit Britain who are the
government agency overall for tourism
and there are significant changes
happening in the tourism destination
management sector
and certainly I can I can reassure you
that our team at Shakespeare's England
work extremely hard and closely with
visit Britain take part in a number of
overseas delegations to attract overseas
visitors plus also spend a lot of their
time and in fact are investing in more
content for their social media platforms
particularly to address more UK visitors
to come and stay a bit longer in
Stratford and The Wider District not
just as a one-day event their key
objective is to encourage visitors to
stay longer thank you
thank you Council Council Curtis do you
have a supplementary question
yes thank you chair and thank you to the
councilor film for the reply
um whilst we welcome these considerable
resources in the climate change fund
which uh was a liberal Democrat
initiative
it seems that the climate emergency
isn't really reflected well in the
actual spend I think members of the
public May wonder why
in cabinet on the 13th of February the
portfolio holder Council of Fleming
rejected the liberal Democrats proposal
to give rural communities access to
climate change funding
he said this would be a side door rather
than these projects coming face to face
at climate change panel
the leader agreed telling tablet and
members of the public that there is a
process set up
so on 27th of February in full Council
the conservatives including all those
representing rural Wards voted
unanimously
to reject our proposals to support rural
Village Halls climate change initiatives
however two weeks later
on the 11th of March I'm seriously
Curtis please can I have a question yes
I'm getting to the question I know you
are but please can I have the question
the portfolio holder told me we don't at
present have a vehicle for grant funding
individual projects and the director of
climate change told me on the 30th of
March there is no grant funding
available for this type of work so my
question is to the portfolio holder
having rejected the lib then proposals
for rural community climate change
projects can the portfolio kindly
explain clearly to council and more
importantly members of rural communities
precisely what this process is to which
he refers
thank you chair
yeah thanks for the like the question
when we eventually got to it
um
like I said before when I spoke to you
by email and there is no system at the
moment that I'm aware of that lets
people apply directly for those funds
we're looking at that that's part of the
process that we're looking at so that it
makes it easy for people to access the
money and more than that I can't say but
I will be Consulting with officers and
with the cabinet to see how we can make
it move forward this is a substantial
sum of money we want to make sure it
gets to the right people and we'll make
sure that that happens thank you
thank you members right moving on to
questions to the leader may I please ask
members that we stick to the business of
this Council
Council Jun Edward was first then
Council project
I just want to follow up on a question
that I actually put to the leader
um are in on the 27th of February 2023
which was about postal votes and I was
given a full response and the response
that came back was that a code of
conduct would be available to all
councilors candidates agents not to
handle completed postal vote
applications and then they be returned
directly to the returning officer
because there was an article in the I
newspaper recently uh that had a
question in there uh and a comment
raised by the Electoral commission about
the handling of postal vote applications
could I ask the leader again what has
that code of conduct be made available
and are all parties that are standing in
this election uh following that because
as I have been made aware
um there are voters who have received
poster vote applications from a
particular party's office with a free
post envelope addressed to the the local
Association and not to the council and I
was assured that this code of conduct
would be followed in this area to make
sure that that did not happen could you
confirm that that code of conduct is
being looked at
this is a matter I'll have to take up
with the returning officer to make sure
I've got an absolutely accurate response
counselor during it
thank you Council fujik
thank you chairman um
since been elected in 2015.
this District Council hasn't been able
to single Council house
it hasn't also built any Council houses
in the last 22 years since the
conservatives have been in power
why has your party leader made a
political choice not to build a single
Council house
thank you I think the reality is
councilor foytic that that die was cast
when we actually got rid of the housing
revenue account on all the existing
housing stock
we have looked a number a number of
times whether or not to build houses
and it is far from Easy
to do so partially because of the price
of housing in Stratford and the massive
sums that will be required to make any
difference
it is something that can be kept under
review but the reality actually is once
the decision was taken to sell our
existing housing stock and cease having
a housing revenue account it is very
difficult to restart that
thank you councilor O'Donnell
are you sitting
income then I shall begin and rather
fittingly so close to Shakespeare's
birthday share with you a work of
fiction indeed I was reminded of the
words of Isabella in measure for measure
truth is truth to the end of Reckoning
I seek clarification around facts raised
in a highly misleading local election
leaflet by the liberal Democrats in
wellsborn
some of the items raised do not even
come under Stratford District Council
but Warwickshire County Council
however regarding those relating to SDC
can you clarify the following
are we building 2 000 new homes in
wellsborn
where is the investment Zone and why
don't we know more about it
and how can you rest at night knowing
proper services such as the police are
no longer in wellsborn but now in
southern thank you
thank you councilor O'Donnell and some
very interesting questions I have to say
that one of my hobbies is actually
reading fantasy
and best works are all with about
quality consistency and rigor of
creating a believable reality
from what you say to the liberal
Democrats
fail on all counts
if one looks at the issues and options
paper of the local plan
there's in the entire 207 pages
of the document there's not a single
reference to any number of homes
allocated to any specific location in
Wellsboro or anywhere else
there is no investment Zone planned for
anywhere in Warwickshire
um
as far as I know
that
policing in wellsborn has not been
abandoned and transferred to Southern
so there seems to be an awful lot of
misleading statements
put around
so I hope counselor O'Donnell you've
been reassured by what I've said
thank you councilor Fielding
thank you chair
um
in
2019 I set up a police
um crime forum which has
helped within the rural community the
rural priests rural Police Squad
I've been asked to set one another one
up
um but I will no longer be standing as a
district councilor would I be supported
by the district council if such as
matter was taken further forward
I think there's a general rule councilor
feel in anything that actually helps uh
commit Community safety would be
supported
Council Jennings
thank you
what does the leader think are the keys
to having an effective and decisive
Council that gets things done
thank you
a very interesting question
I think one of the critical things is
actually having a high caliber Council
team and the cabinet willing to put the
time and effort in and I think one
should be under No Illusion how much
time and effort it actually takes
to get the work of the council done
I think that also comes with strong
teamwork and commitment
there is absolutely no doubt about it
teamwork is vital
um
I think also we need a strong and
capable officer team willing to engage
thoroughly
and robustly
and that's what makes the difference
and it's about a willingness to face a
challenging situations and take
difficult decisions
on between both the cabinet
and the officers and within both it's
all about a level of trust that enables
you to rely on people and ensure they
will actually get done what they say
they will get done
I think as well
and this is I think going to be ever
more important
it's a willingness to look ahead to see
what's coming down the track
and a willingness to take tough
decisions
are for the benefit of the district so I
think that's the keys to having an
effective and decisive Council
thank you Council Crump
thank you Mr chairman first of all as an
ex-local government officer of 30 plus
years I certainly appreciate all the
great work our officers do for us and
support us and and certainly I think
sometimes members sometimes have
unrealistic expectations of them but
that's just a prefix to my comment uh
question over the last three years there
have been several
European worldwide events such as covid
the war in Ukraine the energy crisis
that has had a significant impact on SDC
and its residents and as councilor Perry
said the fourth worst hit is in terms of
Tourism and income
as this Council draws to a close what
does the leader see is the big issues
facing the next Council
foreign
thank you councilor Crump a remarkably
testing question if I'm here says
and I think picking up some of the
points you've actually made
uh I think a lot of people actually
assume that given we've had to tackle
kovid and the cost of living crisis
the next few years might be easier
I'm not sure that's true
I think for the start we've got a major
issue in actually getting the local plan
approved
and the local plan is absolutely
critical because it provides a
foundation for tackling climate change
it provides a foundation for delivering
the housing that the district needs
it's also important to make sure that we
retain control of development so that we
are not overwhelmed by development where
we don't want it
and it's about really importantly
getting the infrastructure we need in
place
as if that weren't enough I think the
next issue is going to be about finance
and budgeting
uh the reality actually is as we've seen
there are serious limits on what the UK
government can borrow
so I think Council finances over the
next four years are not going to get any
better
to be under considerably more stress and
it is very interesting that already D
look have been asking questions about
Reserves
so I would not expect things to become
easier
that means there we are going to be for
whoever forms the next Council there
will be some difficult choices ahead
I think the other thing that we have
been doing and I think it is absolutely
vital that we continue with this is
supporting economic growth and
development across the district and
that's meant working with the university
Warwick is met working with the growth
company and he's met working with the
growth Hub and the porter Brook rail
Innovation Center
I do know that an awful lot of residents
think this is something that the council
should not get to involved in I think
they're absolutely wrong I think it is
actually vital to create a prosperous
District where there are plenty of
employment opportunities and we can all
thrive
and I think in some senses it comes back
to the Christian counselor Jennings
posed
that he's going to put an awful lot of
pressure
on counselors on members of cabinet
and on offices and I think that should
not be underestimated as a challenge
thank you Casper together
thank you chair
only just over a third of local
councilors in the UK are women 36
percent according to figures by the
equality charity the faucet Society only
18 of 382 councils have minimum gender
representation parity at the moment
Stratford District Council only has 33
percent women representation
what is the council done to attract more
women to our Council for example israfo
District Council offering formal
parental leave policies to counselors
and if not why
thank you for your question Chancellor
together
I think part of this it is up to people
who want to put themselves to be
counselors to put themselves forwards
it is then up to whichever party they
are a member of to select them
uh the reality is if people do not want
to stand
then they will not end up as counselors
thank you Council Parry
thank you chair
um firstly can I congratulate and thank
our lead our leader for certainly for
for the last four years of steering this
council
with such great success through so many
difficult times
I'd also like to thank you for for my
ward members across wellsborn for the
protection of wellsborn Airfield
from saving us from having 1500 homes by
adopting such a smart move
in initiating the compulsory purchase
order
therefore could I possibly ask the
leader
on the back of his last four years what
are your three
most
the best achievements you think you have
actually made as a contribution to the
council
I know there are many but I would just
like to know
your three top achievements thank you
could I ask the question is this a
council meeting or is it a political
rally
at this moment their questions are
pertinent to this Council so I've
accepted all them so far
so I've been as Fair as I can possibly
be so thank you
um
thank you councilor Perry it is quite
humbling I think
tackling the kovid crisis was actually a
real challenge
and I think that's where
the teamwork aspect really came in with
both cabinet and offices and everyone
Rose to the challenge
and I do think that's one of the things
it it's not about
individuals it's actually about team
I have to say I think
wellsborn Airfield
has been an ongoing saga for the last
four years
and I think
councilor Pemberton
has played an excellent role in that in
communicating with the residents of
Wellsboro
it has required
an awful lot of
backbone to maintain the threat of
compulsory purchase but it's delivered
and I think that's really important at
the end of the day
having that in place has enabled us to
get
where I think we needed to be
thank you Council kettle
oh thank you Mr chairman leader
uh we do have a question earlier on
about affordable homes
um would you support me in thinking that
when in 2122
a record 495 new affordable homes were
built
and that since the beginning of the core
strategy period
3204 affordable homes
um have been built in this District
enabling those residents who need
affordable homes to have access to them
and that the the rapid increase that we
have had in delivering those is a
success for this Council
I would fully endorse what you said
councilor Kettle I think it has been a
notable achievement
Council Fielding
your second question thank you
um I believe in the county
Berkshire County Council there is an
officer there that can help people who
have certain I wouldn't say disabilities
but for certain problems
I've been it's been I've been identified
of being on the cusp of autism I know
I've got dyslexia and probably a ADHD it
would be useful to get some help from
the council in these matters however I
must apologize because of these problems
to everybody I have upset in the council
uh particularly the staff
but I also apologize to all those that I
haven't
so I would like to know that there is
going to be somebody looking after
people like myself in the new Council
thank you councilor Fielding I don't
think I need to respond to much of that
Council Mills
thanks Mr chairman
um
leader
the little level of council tax to be
charged by other Borough and District
councils in the county for a Bandy
property r
um North Warwickshire is
228.86 nuneaton bedworth or bedith
255.94 rugby 210 84 Warwick
176.86 and Stratford is 159.
may I ask what is the relevance I'm
currently and this is part of my
question thank you if you don't mind me
carrying on thank you very much
other than Warwick District Council
autistic Council boroughs choose to
increase their council tax
can you please let me know how this
conservative LED Council managed to
achieve this while making tough but
prudent decisions to protect our
residents thank you Mr chairman I'm
sorry I carried on too long
only just forgiven
you're too kind
thank you councilor Mills
uh
I think part of it is actually taking
tough decisions
and one of those was about the Greenways
charge there is no doubt about it that
without the green waste charge our
finances would look nowhere near as
secure as they do
uh without the green waste charge we
will probably be cutting services very
significantly
I think the other thing is the duties
about
very prudent budgeting
making absolutely sure that we are on
top
of
the finances and making sure we actually
take a long-term view hence the
five-year medium-term financial plan
we only need to do a three year one but
doing a five-year one gives us a much
better picture of what's coming down the
track for the future and it is very
important to manage within that context
thank you uh Council Ian franchi
uh thank you chair
um in response to a question I asked at
the last meeting the leader responded
um that the rate the regular meeting
that previously occurred between the
police the County Council and the
district council needed to be restored
to a greater frequency
uh please could you give an update on
the time and timetable in achieving this
uh in all honesty Council of fragile I
think that is going to be one for the
next Council
Curtis
thank you chair and finally gone from
councilor Jennings extremely helpful
question regarding qualities of
counselors
um does the leader consider that
um good attendance record and full-time
residency within the district are
important
thank you
thank you councilor Curtis uh it will be
cruel of me to suggest you could also
apply that to the Town Council uh
uh I would tend to agree with you
however like I say perhaps you should
apply it to the other Council you are on
as well
Council Foreman
thank you chair leader how important is
it do you think the councilors to
represent their constituents by making
decisions at Council and not abstaining
ah I think I think
counselor Foreman uh that is a really
interesting question I do think
counselors should be willing to take
decisions
I think they should either can I just I
don't believe that this is irrelevant
because it is an individual
um point for counselors if they wish to
abstain on something
right unless you'll move on to council
Junior second question
sorry my question is um could you the
the Gateway project has taken 10 years
and we've now been told that there's
going to be another two years extension
when do you anticipate a final solution
being found
the final solution is not in my gift
and this is one of the issues with
anything like this much of the Gateway
site is actually owned by a private
individual through a corporate structure
the reality is there have been
negotiations going on for a long time
with this individual
uh
until there is a Meeting of Minds
things will not progress
we have done everything we can to
expedite the issue I have to say I have
no idea how much longer it will take but
I am hopeful
that things are slowly
moving to a conclusion but I think it is
absolutely important that people know
that on issues like this it really does
depend on negotiations and it is not
directly under the control of the
council
thank you our last question now counts
are off
foreign
I wonder if I could ask you
if you would ask your portfolio holder
counselor Trevor Harvey if he would like
to apologize
for putting in a public document that
the conservatives were supporting the
Fred West Center
and not the Fred winter center now I
know councilor Harvey didn't mean it
uh but it has upset an awful lot of
people and I do think I think that's it
mayhem thank you that's certainly
something between obviously your
question is to cancer Harvey it's not
through them leader I just don't believe
that is correct now the leader
you can certainly email him and by all
means do so and I'm sure of that but if
it was an error then it was a very
unfortunate error
right thank you very much indeed let's
moving on from questions
we're going now to item 13 after the
geologist of leader questions uh item 13
is for information only it is the
Housing Association emotion update
uh item 14
there's the emotions on notice provision
of community Public Access
defibrillators on new developments
proposed by Council O'Donnell and a and
secondary by accounts and Mills
um do I have a proposal secondary are
you happy to do that
thank you chair um I would like to
propose this
um motion and also just to quickly place
on record my thanks to councilor Tom
Stowe of Cotswold District Council for
sharing the basis of this potentially
life saving initiative
thank you did I not have a second to
please yes I can second that Mr chairman
thank you thank you this item will now
be referred to cabinet for consideration
item the next item then is
so say same item okay
um item two impact of a solar farm
development as is proposed by councilor
Donald and uh executive by Council Mills
councilor O'Donnell do you want to
propose this one thank you chair I would
and also I'd like to play some record my
thanks to councilor Caroline Newton of
South Oxfordshire District Council again
for sharing the basis of this
um motion thank you thank you and do I
have a second for that yes Miss gem like
a second that thing thank you very much
indeed those items will now be referred
to cabinet thank you
I have no more business uh urgent
business I just like to say again I
reiterate thank you members
you've all put a lot of hard work into
this Council and I think it shows
so thanks very much indeed those who are
definitely not standing that myself
included on that one au revoir and those
who aren't successful in the elections
perhaps we'll meet again there's a song
in there somewhere thank you very much
indeed everybody
animating